the Democrats impeachment spectacle
returning to Capitol Hill you're looking
live as the House Rules Committee
continues to set guidelines for a debate
and full House vote expected tomorrow
but the real fireworks are going down in
the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer are waging war over potential
witnesses the house chose this road it's
their duty to investigate it's their
duty to meet the very high bar for
undoing a national election the house
has built a very strong case against the
president maybe that's why
leader McConnell doesn't seem to want
witnesses at least not agree to them now
and president Trump hammering Nancy
Pelosi over impeachment in a letter
saying that the Democrats are declaring
open war on American democracy here is
the president earlier I've not seen it
look at say a hoax the whole impeachment
thing is a hoax
we look forward to getting onto the
Senate we're not entitled to lawyers
were not entitled to witnesses were not
entitled to anything in the house it's a
total sham I've never seen the
Republican party so United we've got far
less about as you know we got a hundred
percent of the vote I believe the Senate
is equally as well United I watched
Mitch McConnell this morning I watched
numerous people last night the senators
and I think we're equally what United
all right so Dana we assume they're
gonna impeach tomorrow in the house and
now we're looking forward to what's
gonna happen in the US Senate now
they're jockeying for position who do
you think's winning that the pre-fight
fight I think a couple things if you are
looking at the polls either the national
ones are in the battleground states I
think that if you as the prosecution
that Democrats have the burden of proof
right and you have not moved the needle
at all then I think the Republicans or
I've actually done very well so far one
of the things that is a big complaint
right now as they figure out the rules
is that the Senate is looking at the
house saying but you didn't even call
these witnesses before so why should we
call them now they didn't even try they
never went
Cordova and in 1999 Chuck Shumer had a
different position he's explained that
in his own way but you could also find
Republicans also changing their position
from 1999 to today the thing is is that
the house made a house of straw not a
house of bricks watch yeah that was
actually a metaphor coming later in the
d-block let me go back to this because
it's such a good one I'm gonna save it
for then I think I do think that the
Republicans have the upper hand here but
I also believe that once they get
through this once you turn the page on a
new year it would be a good thing for
everybody to have a motion to dismiss
and get it over with
and Greg Dana mentioned Chuck Schumer
kind of changing his position from the
90s let's listen to that and then you
can respond any fair process would be
consulting the White House because it's
the president who's the defendant and
due process would guarantee him or
fairness certainly would guarantee him
certain rights it seems to me that no
good case has been made for witnesses we
ought to be doing instead of this is
doing what the American people want us
to do which is make the schools better
and preserve Social Security and rein in
the HMOs hypocrite hey look if he got
any dumber he would be a bag of clams he
is saying in one breath we've built a
strong case but we need more witnesses
if you have a strong case you don't need
any more witnesses but also the whole
idea of expecting the Senate to call
witnesses is hilarious if you've already
won the case which Trump has there's no
way it's gonna be a piece we already
know this again it's like we already
we've already seen this movie
why call more witnesses to expand with
more stuff to be looked at if you if you
win if you are about to win a
discrimination case you call more
witnesses on your behalf
no you don't you don't have to do that
there's no chance of him being impeached
in the Senate so you'll want to give
them more free swings of the bat last
the idea of Schumer talking about
fairness nothing is fair in politics and
it's a pointless argument because you
always see your side right or left as
being the disadvantage no one ever comes
up to you Oh Dana you know I think I'm
really getting the better end of this
deal no one has ever said that in the
history of anything now so everybody
always sees their side as being at the
disadvantage so just saying it's not
fair
waste your oxygen and waste our time so
just get rid of that argument and just
assume that people are going to disagree
with you and you're gonna disagree with
that one would you like to respond to
the fairness because you know in the
house the Democrats denied all
Republican witnesses and now Chuck
saying oh no you should treat us fairly
after the Republicans got railroaded in
the house you know sometimes I listen
and I just get dizzy because let me get
this straight the thoughts are too quick
oh we don't need to hear from Hunter
Biden Joe Biden and we don't because
they're not the ones who are on trial
here in terms of impeachment lou
president don't forget sudden don't make
me hungry any efforts to distract are
legitimized by this you know what about
is it's ridiculous here's what happened
today the president sends a letter to
nancy pelosi that's essentially a scream
from a guilty man he says you know i
can't argue with you but I'm gonna call
you names I'm gonna say this a hoax I'm
gonna say that was a perfect call you
know what Jesse 70% of Americans
including Republicans say you did
something wrong mr. president that's not
right to try to use your power as a
represent the United States to get
information on your political opponent
don't do it you shouldn't have done it
but it's only because and this comes
back to Greg's point it's only because
Republicans insist oh you know what
I'm gonna just be totally loyal I'm
gonna I'm a Republican so I won't look
at the facts and that goes to what's
going on that's not what I said
you have to like different something you
don't have to make up new stuff it the
facts are so you're like Adam Schiff
yeah you take a story and then you
regurgitate it with like completely
nonsensical facts I think nothing like
that well because you know what if
something if the Democrats were in fact
run the drains if Trump witness in that
letter you know that's true
we do that for three years you're acting
like his own words when they are laugh
aloud or aggressive or funny somehow
proof of guilt here's the laughable to
all of America perfect call no problem
because he's gonna lose in the Senate
Republicans who were on the House
Judiciary Committee who've said publicly
do I think it was a perfect call no do I
like what the president said no is it an
impeachable offense absolutely not and
that is where in the majority of the
country is which is proven by the way
that the polls have been going down on
behalf of the narrative for the
Democrats and up for President Trump in
terms of his approval and what
Republicans are doing and how they're
handling this but back to the process
here of where we're going forward
Democrats set the low standard of
impeachment in the house so for Chuck
Schumer now to laughably ask for some
kind of fairness is just a big joke and
the White House now has an opportunity
and so do Senate Republicans to say
let's quit while we're ahead the numbers
politically are good for us we don't
benefit by bringing someone like hunter
Biden or anyone else in front of the
Senate to testify because then Democrats
do get other witnesses to come and talk
under oath and I think the Democrats are
very severely under estimating the
blowback in Trump districts who have now
have Democrat representatives in
Congress who are basically saying we
know better than you we don't believe
that your vote counts and now we're
going to make a decision to impeach the
president and in that letter today to
Nancy Pelosi he president Trump wasn't
just talking to Pelosi he was defending
himself putting himself in historical
record and also he mentions the voters
and he's talking about how the Democrats
are attacking millions of people around
the country with this charade that
they've done and so if the Democrats
have the hard the clear-cut case their
numbers would be higher and Chuck
Schumer wouldn't be asking for it I
don't know how there could be higher
Katie bear already there's almost spot
free half the country thinks that number
two months you should be in peace and
guess what when it was Clinton it never
got above 29 don't ruin the show is
outrage the show we know you're upset
and that's because you're losing and
that's okay no
I think America is a great country we
should protect the Constitution's like
this authoritarian you're changing the
Constitution first time I heard you
talking about protecting the
Constitution oh I did hear more of that
from you all right go for it